سالنا ناس في مصر هل اظهار الثراء امام
الناس مقبول ام مرفوض بمعنى اخر هل تقول
فلوسي وانا حر فيها ام تشعر بالاخرين
نتابع الاجابات
بحل البلد ده اللي احنا فيه متهيالي مرفوض
قوي يعني وبعدين انا ابين ليه للناس ان
انا في في عندي ثراء جامد زياده عن اللزوم
كده وغيري كتير قوي قوي ومحتاج معاك فلوس
ومرتاح وكويس اعيش حياتك ان انت تظهرها
قدام الناس بقى بمنظر كدهوت يعني بتتباع
انت كده بتبقى بتتباها قوي وعايز تبين
للناس ان انت معك فلوس وبس انما يعني
بتكهر ناس تانيه في حياتها لازم يكون في
مراعاه لشعار الاخرين ولازم يكون في تقدير
للناس برده اللي هي في الشارع مثلا معاش
فلوس معاش تاكل اصلا
[موسيقى]
الماده
الظاهر بيها قدام الناس قدام الفقير طبعا
بيبقى محتاج غصب عنه طبعا ايه بيبقى محتاج
يعني ده بيبقى محتاج فلوسي اللي هو يوسف
واللي معاه الفلوس بيتباع بيها ليه لا
طبعا امر مرفوض عشان مراعاه طبعا الشعور
الاخرين اللي هم طبعا الناس اللي ما فيش
اصلا امكانيه لها اي حاجه في البلد ممكن
نعمل كده بس يعني من غير ما حد ما يعرف ده
كانت بره نساعدهم بطريقه ما حدش مش ملحوظه
ما حدش عارف دي حاجه بيننا وبين ربنا يعني
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات